what i find in negotiations in real life
is the absolute failure on the part of
so many people to not anticipate
what you will be asked
i'm joe navarro former fbi agent and
body language expert asking for a raise
haggling in a market deciding where to
go for dinner
interviewing a suspect all of these
are a form of negotiation every
successful
negotiation follows a pattern there's
the assessment phase
the engagement phase and the
transactional phase
if any one of these fail
at worst you have a disaster at best
this process takes forever
so if you were to ask me well when you
were in the bureau
what things did you do to negotiate
effectively
right off the top i i would tell you
planning
sitting down with you know yellow legal
pads and writing
out what is my objective clearly define
what is the objective here what words am
i going to use with this individual
if you're talking to to a ceo that has
two degrees
what are you going to use fourth grade
words
you have to think of the audience you
have to think of what potentially
they're going to throw at you and not
just
what they may throw at you how quickly
they will throw it at
you somebody that thinks fast speaks
fast you're gonna have to be able to
throw that arrow back
immediately so it's planning it's
coordinating it's rehearsing
sitting down with fellow agents and
saying okay
you're gonna play the part of the bad
guy and yet i've been to
you know observer of many a negotiation
where there's this
absolute failure to think about what
will be asked
and this all goes to you know winging it
thinking that negotiations is just about
the transaction showing up and saying
what maybe you've thought about
when in fact the front end should be
what takes up the most time
one of the jobs of the fbi was to
recruit individuals who were working for
hostile intelligence services
they would often be in the united states
under different cover
as students working with companies and
so forth
but it's not like you can walk up to
somebody and say
hey hi i'm joe and we know you're spying
and please tell us everything
so it was a matter of letting them know
that i was an agent of the fbi
and how can we begin to at least talk to
each other
and what i found useful always
was i would find them on the street
and i would just begin to walk with them
and if they carried the newspaper in the
left hand i carried the newspaper in the
left hand
by mirroring their behavior they don't
feel threatened
but then next time when they see me
again walking next to them
they're saying wait a minute there are
no coincidences in
counter-intelligence work and then i can
begin a process
of engagement that is a benign
so one of the things that i found as an
fbi agent in just
trying to get people to either confess
or cooperate with us
was what came to be known as the
empathic model
of social interaction and the empathic
model basically
looks at human communications and says
in every effective negotiation
you have the assessment phase the
engagement phase
and then the transactional phase we look
at assessment as
all the information that we can gather
ahead of time
plus what we can read from this person
the minute we come into visual contact
and then throughout the process
and so subconsciously by approaching
this individual
and just mirroring their behaviors
they're thinking
this is a pro this guy knows how to do
it this guy
knows that i may be under surveillance
but this looks natural the engagement
phase
is thinking about well where's the best
place to meet him
how how many people look i'd like to
meet you at this bar
but if that's going to cause you
problems or it's going to
force you to have to report it then you
tell me where you want to meet
and then lastly it's the transactional
phase where at some point
we now cross over into what is our goal
and objective
i want this person to cooperate but
that's not going to take place
until i can coordinate the assessment
and the engagement then it allows us to
move into the transactional phase
much more easy i'm always assessing i'm
always
trying to figure out the best way to
engage and then what is the best way
to transact
one of the things that i always looked
at is a term
we coined called chronicity and that is
how we use
time we know that for instance for
doctors
surgical accidents increase after the
lunch hour
parole boards are more willing to
be lenient in the morning hours less so
in in the afternoon so a lot of that has
to do with both the circadian rhythm
and blood sugars and so as i look at
negotiations and law enforcement i need
to factor
when is this person the most able to
resist me
versus okay at this point there's going
to be less
resistance negotiations are temporal
whoever dominates time is in charge
so you call a little time out let's go
talk that changes the rhythm
that changes where this is going when do
i remain silent
there's a client i've worked with and he
said joe
i i can't tell you how many times i've
used silence in fact i was negotiating
for a building
with a father and a daughter and they
made a
an offer that was supposed to be like
their final offer
and i just sat there and lowered my eyes
and it drove them crazy
and finally the daughter said okay we're
gonna throw in another million dollars
and he wasn't expecting that he was just
expecting them to say
this is it
one of the things that i learned as an
agent especially
dealing with extremists is
that you just let them vent and
not just let them vent once but let them
vent
over and over and over and over and just
when you think they're shutting down
you say well tell me about that again or
would you cover that again
and what happens is second law
thermodynamics
entropy after a while they've grown
so tired they've got so much negative
emotions
poured into this that eventually they
wear out and it leaves you in a better
position
to then negotiate i've talked with a lot
of
airlines over the years and one of the
things that we say
is that when you have a customer
especially at the gate
and they're being very vociferous let
them vent
let them vent let them vent and then
eventually all that energy is
just dissipated entropy takes over
and then you can say look this is what
we can do
for you and and that's all
[Music]
one of the most difficult cases that i
that i ever had involved a man he was in
his
late 30s and he was a pedophile
we knew there were at least two
photographs of what he had done
but we knew that these individuals
collected
a lot more and the question was number
one
where was it number two would he
cooperate with us and number three
would he confess to all these crimes
and the difficulty was when we assessed
this individual
he seemed like a nice guy in the sense
that if you ran into him on the street
you wouldn't
perceive him as being a pedophile but at
the same time i was assessing myself
and that was how angry i was that i was
sitting with this individual
so i had my emotions to deal with but i
have to negotiate
with him i have to get this information
out of him
somehow and to do so i had to
go through that process of assessing him
he says he's a churchgoer okay he says
that he studied
and graduated from high school and so
forth so i'm building up
all these things that i can at least
attach some humanity to
how to engage him became
immensely difficult i have to
remain even and and and get the
information
out of him and then i have to be careful
about what language i use
because if i say the wrong word
such as girl or child
he may just all of a sudden rear up and
shut down
so it's about proceeding incrementally
constantly assessing him watching his
breathing rate watching his blink rate
watching how often he touched his neck
or he looked at me
were his hands flat palmed down on his
knees
or were his fingers gathered up
and after an hour i'm understanding him
better we're now establishing uh
communications more effectively
and i said let me tell you about my
situation
i'm a father i'm also an agent i'm not
gonna go away
i have people that i report to and
finally i said to him look
i'm probably the only guy in this town
that doesn't hate you right now there's
a thousand people out here
that would string you up right now but
i'm talking to you
i'm listening to you and in doing that
he understood where i was coming from no
badge no
gun no authority figure just this is who
i
am and then he explained his position
my life is ruined i'm going to lose my
job i'm gonna go to prison
blah blah blah yeah most likely
now we've established who we are as as
humans
and then i said well the first thing you
could do
is be helpful you know be helpful to me
forget the us attorney forget the
prosecutors
i need this and now it's personal
and so he immediately told me where the
rest of the material was
now is this earth shattering does it
save a nation state
no but i look at that as
one of the most important cases i i ever
worked
and i attribute that success
really not to myself but to this model
that in in some ways it's it's really
perfect